parents in shock as gorillas mate in
front of kids at Zoo
a pair of gorillas at a zoo
left parents shocked as they decided to
start doing it like they do on the
Discovery Channel right in front of the
kids
when you take the kids to the zoo to see
all the wonders of the animal kingdom
you've always got to understand there's
a risk that all creatures great and
small will be up to some naughty antics
I love this
hell I think the zoo could charge more
for animal sex hours honestly
if you come at 2 p.m that's when
everybody's [__] you know what I'm
saying bruh
because you go to some of these cages
now you go to the lion cage he's in
there he's always sleeping or he's laid
out or he's on looks like he's on a
couple zannies you know
they always got a kit ball next to him
you who's ever seen a lion play kickball
what [__] lion gets up and he's like
then you see another lion run up and
just
and the other lions are like Roar kick
it kick it it's [__] there's no [__]
that's what do they do they're not doing
anything
and then and there's always like a tight
rope in the cage going from like one
tree to another
like the line like the Lion's just gonna
like oh just like Walk On The Relic oh
I'm a rope lion I'm a tired rope lion
[__] what the [__]
they don't do [__] man
I'm sick of paying entry fees to see
animals not do [__] they don't do [__]
these animals don't do [__] they just
lay there like Rich animals that's all
they are
because we took them out of the Wild
the wild is where God is out there
setting it off
and Mother Nature's out there [__]
twerking
and people are eating BBQ and getting
gunned down
but we take them out of the natural
environment we put them in this Rich ass
[__] Maxim or minimum security prison
and they're living large they're
kickballing they're eating lamb they're
I saw one video they're feeding lamb to
Lambs
I'm sick of these rich ass animals
that's all this is man have you ever
lived in a shitty neighborhood and then
moved to a better neighborhood
have you ever moved from Memphis to
Nashville
okay that's what's happening with these
animals
and people are like well we got to set
the animals free
no we what
if we set the animals free every penguin
will be at in at Albertsons in the
frozen food section
you'll have every penguin in there
[__] just just beating open a thing
of fish sticks
every leopard will kill every missing
pet in your area
there will be zero missing animals
you can't free you can't free these
animals man
because they'll be right back in nature
they'll be right back in the wild
and the wild the wildest gangster
that's the UFC for Animals man
these animals they have a good in the
zoo they got it really really good
so why say we either put them to work or
tell them to take a four-legged hike
I want to go to the zoo and they got I
want to go during they should have
animal sex hours in the afternoon two to
three p.m everybody [__]
all right forty dollars to get in
you that Zoo would be packed
that Zoo would be even the French would
be there like um
but we got to get these animals to work
these Zoo they're not making any money
nobody's going to see that you could
watch a nationally fight immediately
The Dana White should do the nature
Channel
these [__] fight immediately on the
nature Channel
so these animals I think they either
need to step it up or get the hey
that's what I'm saying I want to go to
the zoo I want to see you know I want to
see uh I want to see the end I want to
see these Apes fists fighting I want to
see the rats making soup like they do in
the movie I want to see
um Penguins miming why aren't Penguins
miming
you got the colors do the [__] work
boys
but zoos could easily Step It Up 2 p.m
all the animals [__]
that's easy
2 p.m all the animals [__] 40 dollars to
get in bring a rain Slicker boom
now we're talking business baby
but I think if you go to the zoo and see
some animals [__] lucky you all right
just make sure that you have a
conversation with your son or daughter
afterwards to explain what happened and
that they shouldn't feel ashamed for
watching it
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one